I'm so bored right now why don't you
take your [ __ ] out and wait when the
doctor comes and you should take your
pants down make it look like we're just
[ __ ] I'll give you a thousand bucks
when the doctor walks into you're naked
with a tongue depressor up your ass
what's up potato chips and M&Ms don't
mind if I do
orange that's my jam oh how about giving
me some [ __ ] chicken fingers for free
get some [ __ ] quesadillas going damn
man you get free potato chips too is it
unlimited M&Ms do you know I went to
ivillage.com and they list 32 ways of
knowing if your husband's having an
affair and you are guilty of 18 number
16 would rather watch TV than have sex
number 18
your mate turns to the table and accuses
you of cheating why do you listen to
new-age music now why are you trying new
sex positions with me why are you
working out what is that finger thing
you do I swear to God you said a Chinese
woman's name in your sleep I thought you
didn't like you teach I thought it was
lowbrow I thought it was lowest common
denominator it did suck it did before
they hired one of the writers from Six
Feet Under and took a whole new tone
with the show it's suck and so they got
a hilarious new Kramer like presence to
the show until they hired one of the
writers from Dharma and Greg and the
show became [ __ ] amazing
until that changed the whole direction
of the show and hired one of the writers
from Dexter you piece of [ __ ] that's not
as weird as getting drunk and having sex
with a guy from yo teach so when I first
moved here I blew Alf when I first moved
here I had sex with Trapper John MD when
I first moved here I had sex with Steve
Urkel
I gave Tony Danza facial when I first
got to LA it's a date what's that that's
for gay cruises or something I always
see these billboards JDate and see two
guys on a cruise actually I went on a
date recently awesome and that I'm
meeting your mother I would like to get
on to a day two the only problem is I
don't like Jews I think they're greedy
so there's a whole list out there of
women who act like my mother I got I got
I gotta get on that yes you remind me of
a girl I used to date in Hebrew school
yeah well actually a boy I used to date
did Jeffrey Katz see you're funny to me
I like your sassy attitude your sardonic
huh I love your deadpan you're like a
shooting star is that a real
prescription
they're just for looks you should make a
movie with our dog your dog make some
big poops our dogs better than your dog
you really a mermaid when your mermaid
tail girl one day I'm vomited three
times I don't do it anymore but my [ __ ]
is still great out of plastic no Craig
you're not going to the meeting you're a
baby really I know I'm a baby Tim you
think that point escaped me oh how do
you think I feel my balls haven't
dropped yet
I got a baby dick I never thought I'd be
bored sucking on a Ted well maybe
somebody can change my diaper now please
wipe me why me I have a rash on my dick
which is one inch hard hey don't talk
about mister cuddle bear like that we
have something different I am so sick of
sitting here with poop in my diapers you
guys know each other yes there's a
little play that's splashing Daisy damn
bee
yeah we know each other you made me a
sandwich yesterday panini prosciutto was
nice yeah let's go hook me up with a
little PCP yesterday I still chicken
panini
hey man cheese a little grilled chicken
panini man last time I sorry there you
weren't wearing any gloves that's
unsanitary don't do this to me okay I'm
really go above anything anyone tells me
my friend he told me that he was a tall
dwarf I believed him for three years
they my friend he told me he had three
balls and I felt it and everything and I
believed him they still make fun of me
for it when I was young one of my
friends told me a vagina and the anus
were the same hole I believed in till I
was 16 ever notice your accent makes
things sound worse than they and they
actually are how's James Bond oh and you
get him yet so when did you eat Deon
Borg are you mad at McEnroe for beating
you all those times
so when do I sit here when you start
pulling my molars out I don't know how
this works
can you see me a few songs from Mamma
Mia maybe that'll cheer me up I just
need to know how to get back to Sesame
Street as are you the Swedish Chef from
the Muppet Show didn't you try to kill
Jason Bourne at one point you're great
in Schindler's List I did enjoy you in
Rocky Ford my wife
likes my accent you should not be
calling people Nazis I haven't taken the
time to lose the accent at all no I
assure you I did not eat pure Bach
big bird is not evil your comedic idea
does not track I have to rent that one I
haven't seen that Dolph Lundgren an
excellent actor they told me you are
funny
and you are very funny